so often times when when people
think about it and talk about trauma
what often comes to mind is like oh
anything that's negative right and and
that can lead to to kind of two extremes
right one can be to really minimize and
say hey everybody has negative things
right everyone's everyone's traumatized
in some way and then that can lead
people to sort of discount it right on
the other end if we're painting with too
much of a broad brush there are people
who then
want to say you know every child gets a
trophy or you know we want to stop we
want to start then protecting people
from any adversity right so so trauma is
not you know
anything with a clinical trauma right
it's not anything that's negative right
it is something that is that is negative
in a way that overwhelms our coping
skills right so if it overwhelms our
ability to take it in our ability to
cope with what that trauma is then there
are changes in our brains right so it's
not just like oh it's anything negative
no it's something that rises to the
level where our brain function right and
therefore our psychology right which
which rides upon our brain function is
different going forward and there's
there's hard scientific evidence
about this so it's not a soft
concept right like we know that for
example vigilance mechanisms in the
brain change right after trauma the true
trauma that overwhelms our coping
mechanisms and leaves us different going
forward that all sorts of things shift
inside of us including genetic changes
where it can change how active or not
active
our genes are when we pass them on years
later right to be think about that it's
grounded in the cutting edge of science
but we but we are not applying that
cutting edge of science
in our understanding of like what's
going on in the world around us in our
societies and what's going on in each of
us
so you're saying that so you can have
two people experience the same thing
trauma same same adversity
and one registers at it as an actual
trauma and one doesn't correct
right right and even in the same person
there's something called say the
multiple hit hypothesis which might say
that i might have three four five
traumas maybe right and and they could
look pretty significant from the outside
but they don't overwhelm my coping
mechanisms and change my brain as i go
forward then there might be another one
that might even be much smaller say less
than the magnitude of the previous ones
and that could push a person into now
having basically a post-trauma syndrome
so it varies by person what are our
genetics and are we are genetics
protective or do they make liability for
us what is our prior life experience
been what support mechanisms do we have
around us so it varies across people and
it can also vary within
a person where it might be that fourth
fifth sixth trauma that can then make a
syndrome that didn't occur with the
first wow
how
just to give more insight like given
maybe an anecdotal situation of of
something that would be perceived
to anyone as small like how small can
something get
for the body to register it as a trauma
well i mean theoretically it could get
quite small
very small if
that if the person is particularly
susceptible right so if you imagine
someone who's been in just dire
circumstances right and and they've
gotten through them without being
overwhelmed say the person is made for
being a refugee and you know trying to
escape syria and get from one place to
another and just makes it through and
then gets to a place where seemingly
like okay now
i'm safe right i'm out of i'm out of the
danger right and then imagine in
environments like that if there's some
sort of chronic denigration where the
person is now seen as less than you know
they're ethnically different or their
socioeconomic status is different that
that could push someone to to then
oppose post-trauma syndrome even though
one might think there's nothing even
dramatic going on happening anymore
right right but but you know so much of
what goes on with us like it all goes on
inside of us right and then we we have
to live with the experiences that happen
inside of us and how they
impact us which which is why we need a
health care system that's actually
paying attention to what's going on
inside of us talking to us about it
right as opposed to seeing all of us the
same i mean i think you know the the the
what we've been talking about so far is
like really important right because it's
acknowledging the difference across
human beings that hey we're not all the
same right we don't have the same
genetic makeup we don't have the same
experiences we don't react the same way
and if we look at us all the same right
how are we going to help any of us and
and that's also you know in writing a
book that i wish to be accessible to
anyone right who chooses to pick it up
and read it and entertaining and
engaging that writes about these things
in into the common plain
language right it's so that we can gain
an understanding
not just of what it is but of how do we
prevent it i mean that's ultimately what
we wish to do or how do we recognize it
if it's present how do we treat it
because the systems around us the
medical
systems and mental health care systems
um are doing such a poor job
of that what are kind of the
environmental circumstances that lead to
someone since obviously everyone
registers things different and even that
person individually themselves can
register it different over time or
through repetition
what is it that
what is it that um
that makes your nervous system
uh able to
cope better what are some skills that
would allow you to cope better with
things so that things don't register as
a trauma is that even possible
yeah sure sure you know anything that
that
can put us in lower states of
vulnerability right so if you think i
mean how many people are going through
life even before the pandemic right in
in a state of fairly constant
vulnerability right you know i remember
reading before the pandemic
all this great news about how the
unemployment rate is so low right but
then you would also see news that would
say some really astronomical percentage
of people where you can't survive and
move forward as they're living if they
have like a five or six hundred dollar
expense right and then you think okay
you know we're sort of celebrating that
that there's a low unemployment rate but
but so many people are employed in
sectors where they just can't get ahead
right i mean you think about the service
industry and like how hard it is
maybe even approaching impossible to do
things people could do in the past ready
to buy a home send children to to
college if they choose right
that as all of that changes what ends up
happening is it builds vulnerability
into the system where now people's
medical benefits are tied to a job that
they could lose right or they have a job
but their job doesn't have medical
benefits and you need a job to have
medical benefits or at least you have
historically right in this country we're
doing somewhat of a better
job at that now but you know these
states of vulnerability which can also
come by feeling denigrated in in any way
whether that's because of socioeconomic
status or it's it's around gender or
sexuality right they're they're
they're so many ways in which people are
sort of chronically
denigrated right and and feel a sense of
being less than and and like
that really doesn't help at all with our
resilience mechanisms when something
traumatic happens and the more we're
interconnected with other people there's
friends and family and support networks
around us you know things that we had a
lot more in the past that we now have a
lot
less of so so absolutely we can do
things to predispose us to handle
traumatic things well so that they don't
leave us different going forward right
but unfortunately a lot of what's
happened in the world around us
only brings more vulnerability and
predisposes us to to the negative
reactions inside of us through traumatic
things and how many people have lost
their lives right so how many people are
are
now trying to go forward with lost loved
ones and feeling a sense of
vulnerability they never felt before and
we have such an angry and often
heartless political dialogue around us
that can can we can we
blame
anyone if if most people are feeling
beleaguered and then what are we doing
we're just making soil that's fertile
for the seeds of trauma to fall whether
that's a car accident or it's a death of
a loved one or it's loss of a job or
it's any of the other
millions of things that can that can
happen to us we create fertile ground
for the seeds of trauma to change our
brains to release shame to create fear
in us and to make life worse for us
going forward and i don't think that's
esoteric i mean i think that that's the
common sense read of what's going on
around us i mean i'm trying to put some
structure to it in the book and in this
conversation but i also think that it's
just
eminently obvious just looking at the
world around us what a great perspective
the word that comes to mind the whole
time is
sovereignty
and how
i think i feel like we're all being
called into sovereignty over our bodies
over our minds and that there's so much
being pushed on us that it's like it
kind of
um
is at a breaking point or
being it's we're being pushed so hard
that we need to step into that does that
register is that the right way of
thinking about it
yeah i mean most people are pushed
really hard after these last couple of
years right and most people were pushed
really hard before these last couple of
years i mean look you need look no
further than the opiate epidemic and how
many thousands upon thousands upon
thousands of people
died needlessly
right and how much of that was
desperation when you know the opiates
after the surgery oh didn't just help
the knee pain right but they helped a
greater kind of pain right it kind of
pain inside that then created a
dependence that ended up killing that
person and as someone who's done a lot
of work in that realm over years and
years it's just tragic because it's the
opiate epidemic yes it was a symptom of
many many things um but one of the
things that was a symptom of was the
desperation that's getting built into
all of us right it's getting built into
us as americans and we're not doing a
good job of taking care of ourselves
resources are squandered right we don't
look around us like how can we use our
resources as a society better how can we
use health care resources to actually
treat our health i mean you you look at
what's going on and you say in a way
it's exactly what one would expect right
you know if we all live together on a
street and we said let's not take care
of it anymore right let's have potholes
in the street and who cares if they do
tree limbs fall off and kill somebody
and you know we'll fight with each other
too while we're doing it right are we
really going to be surprised if we run
that forward and we're like wow some of
us are dead right a lot of us are really
at risk or unhappy we're at odds and
like this street that might have been a
lovely place to live before is now going
you know going downhill and it's not for
lack of resources right it's just that
the resources are squandered or we're
just looking at everything through a
lens of
anger and frustration and there's so
much of that in the world where where
you think about the idea of like
the lack of attachment to truth into
fact
right which is you know as a guy who was
a political science major and followed
politics for so many years like at least
people would would like agree if there
was a fact like you know if i were
saying one plus one is three and you're
saying it's two and you can show me that
it's two right you know i think in the
past i was unlikely to double down and
say you know what it's three anyway
right and now i'll attack you personally
right i mean like why you know where
when we do that we
we work so strongly against our own
interests and so much of that comes
because people are just angry and this
is this is how it gets if we're afraid
and we're angry we just want to be right
[Music]